here we go this is Lauren bber thanks
it's always hard whenever um there's
gravity put on the voters I'm here to
provide levity and lift burdens off of
people so hold on pause this already
she's already got hot she's already got
hot girl giving a book
report she's in front of the class cuz
you know she wants to walk up and go
like happen guy had a
hog with that shoulder showing and that
Colorado had
like she bought at DIA she's not a bad
looking woman she's hot she's hot and
she probably walked across the street
being like ah you suck some you
some and you lose some right but see now
she's got a like the gravity she might
as well given tent fingers she's like
the gravity of the
situation this is like when my parents
would be like hey there was a $100 on
the Manel it's not there anymore I'd be
I'd be really high I'd be like well you
know uh the spatial
relationship